This parabola has a vertex at 2, 1. Great work if you found this. We start by
completing the square. We want to add a certain amount in order to make this a
perfect square. We'll need to add four in order to do that. And since we add
four here, let's also subtract four. This keeps our equation balanced. Remember
that to complete the square here, we always add b over 2 squared. The b value
is negative 4, so b over 2 is negative 2, and that amount squared is positive
4. It's the amount we add in order to complete our square. Now we'll be ready
to write this expression as a perfect square. The positive 5 and negative 4
will just stay on the end. Here's our perfect square. And here's our equation,
simplified combining these two numbers. So the vertex is at positive 2 for the
x coordinate, and positive 1 for the y coordinate. Our vertex is here, and we
get it by setting this binomial equal to 0. And the k value, or the y
coordinate of the vertex is k. It's right here, positive 1. Now that we have
our vertex, we can actually plot two other points. The one right next to the
vertex. Our a value is positive 1 so this means we move one unit left and right
at the vertex and then one unit up vertically. That will give us two additional
points. And if we zoom in on our parabola, we can see this more clearly. We
move left one and right one from the vertex. And then we move a units in the
vertical direction, in this case one unit up. So left one and up one and right
one and up one. This gives us our points at 1, 2 and 3, 2. Once we have these
two points we can draw in the basic shape of our parabola. That's how we get
this graph.